you're right
excuse my leg I'm gonna be little doggy
icon cut good see ya hey how's it going
have you done there
come on the schools in Uganda Africa and
I fell down a waterfall
oh yeah broke my Brent my leg could be
bad so it's not a brace
[Music]
[Music]
hi Samuel leaves here and many people
have been asking me for an update on the
castle I'm here right now at the castle
and if you want to know more about this
this building you can just google it
it's called ribs foot house so Google
rib spit out it has its own long
Wikipedia page difficult to really give
a regular update on the castle because
it's a very slow process I'm very used
to kind of going in and you know bang
quick refurb on a property it takes a
few months this this old project on I'm
gonna be interviewing the surveyor and
the p.m. and kamana comb going around
the outside of it things are happening
everything's on track but it is slow so
let me just talk a little bit about
what's going on and and show you around
[Music]
what do you think has taken the most
time and up until now sort of what's
it's it's really just trying to get all
the pull the box tick slot look local
authority anything like this is it's
this stages that we have to follow when
do you think contractors & builders
actually start going in and doing stuff
probably next spring yeah builders will
be going in there probably this side of
Christmas will be getting the quotes
together so that we a package of works
for the safety items yeah they'll be
doing those the consultants will be
going in to do their elements yeah and
then after Christmas once it's safe then
we can start looking at developing a
specification
yeah hit what you want to achieve with
this and how best to utilize the other
areas
[Music]
really nice that you can get a better
view now of the building with the trees
being cut down so there was a lot of big
high trees all up here and over here
which were not only an all I saw from
the inside and from the outside of the
property but also they will make they'll
bring causing damp and problems with the
property because of the condensation
from the trees so we've got a full-time
gardener who is here who's looking after
the ground he's also working as the
caretaker doing a great job all these
trees the plan is to bring these down to
like 6 foot 8 foot so when you arrive
you can see the castle in all its glory
which is great
[Music]
it's great to see that the death of the
Japanese knotweed it is slowly dying so
they're injecting this regularly you're
not allowed to chop it down and throw it
in the tip because it will ruin and
devastate everything it touches so
they're dealing with this Japanese
knotweed was before thriving and looked
like it was ready to eat someone alive
but now it's can definitely see that it
is dying slowly so again it's going to
take a year or two before the Japanese
knotweed is completely gone but it is
under management and we have insurance
on it up to five million pounds so the
Japanese knotweed is officially boom
taking care of which is fantastic great
T star has historical importance you
know we've got so we met a goal has been
here which is why it's got the great up
to star these French soldiers were here
in the Second World War we messed it up
orders too bad it's literally prison
time could be yeah yeah yeah if you
knock down part of this building you'd
be spending time in prison yeah you know
if they there would be steps before that
you know they wouldn't just throw you in
the prison they'd give you a probation
notice and have to put it back within
the morning so for instance those
windows if we hit those windows and took
them away
they issue with a prohibition notice if
that didn't happen didn't work then you
could potentially have like very
significant fine until you put it right
or if you didn't do it and you just try
to get it built
you could you could go to court and you
could find yourself in prison
[Music]
if you plan to fail you fail to plan you
may have heard that saying before I
think one of the big things that's
happening here is it's just the planning
side of things we've got a big property
it's very very protected and has a lot
of work needs to be done we're gonna
spend probably a couple million or so on
the works of this project so I think
that's going really well
Adrian seems happy with the with the
process with the process and where we're
up so so what's going to happen next
well the trees have been mostly cut down
we've got more trees to get chopped down
we've got the roof I think the roof is
the next thing because until the roofs
fixed and the actual building itself is
safe what we can't get the work you know
builders in and the work started so um
yeah coming together this is completely
different from a small project you know
what it's just like bang get in
whip whip round this is this is a
completely different beast but once it's
done it'll be worth it and they say that
all great things if there's no struggle
then there's no satisfaction so the fact
that this is taking a long time you know
it's all part of it and I'm looking
forward to rejoicing when it's done
thank you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time